[Music]
it's good this is an excellent book for
me today you should read that read that
one you go is the enemy my sense is that
you're your ego is is pretty well in
check with all this kind of nonsense and
we were just talking a minute ago about
trying to mute out the extrinsic noise
that accompanies you know doing what you
do yeah I I think it's I think it goes
probably like like the deepest addiction
there is though you know what I mean
I mean I think like the fact that even
the Dalai Lama's like still vying with
it right and I'm named Joe all there's
aspects of it that that are necessary to
being an actual eyes human I think it's
about harnessing you know the power that
it has in keeping you know it's ill
effects you know in check yeah it's all
I mean also it's a word with a lot of
lateral definition and yeah so it
depends on what part of it you know
which version of ego you're talking
about in some ways like because I get I
guess I guess even altruism even even
the impulse to do good what you have to
believe that you have capabilities and
capacity for yourself you can't I mean
look this movie that we're gonna talk
about your you you wrote it you directed
it you star in it it takes a certain
audaciousness to say I can handle this
and with that comes you know an aspect
of ego that is necessary and and crucial
to like getting the job done yeah make
everyone else believe that you have that
capability right that's that yeah what
you're what you're saying I agree that
like if you don't have belief in your
own agency like if you don't have if you
don't have belief that you have capacity
you know you I I actually I actually by
the way this is a digression but it's
Eddings an interesting one I think a lot
of people at their lowest like
depression that the depression and
anxiety that a lot of people feel in the
modern world and a lot of what flows
from it even
in terms of like the socio-political
expressions things that go on like
Briggs it right now which you could say
is like let's even forget America I
think breaks it right now is one of the
most fascinating examples of an enormous
collective unforced error right self
harm that there was no reason to have
inflicted and and I think you could
argue that that sometimes these things
happen when people reach a lack of faith
that they have any agency that they
matter that they when they feel
marginalized to the degree that even the
act of self harm they know it on an
intuitive level they know they're doing
themselves damage but the ability to do
anything that causes anything to happen
is is eluding them in so many other
areas of their life that they do
something sort of openly
self-destructive because at least they
did it yeah the level of
disenfranchisement has to rise to a
certain threshold level and once it tips
over that there's a vibration a
collective you know there's a collective
ability to like tap into a certain
vibration to take an action even with
the understanding that it's not in their
own interest yeah and you see that
played out time and time again I mean
we're seeing it here yeah I and the
funny thing is his ice someone was um
someone's ik waiting it's like niala
that's what nihilism is it's it's the
belief that destruction has its own end
or whatever right I don't think that I
think it's like a front I just I agree
he doesn't mean I'm saying and I was
kind of wincing I was like that's not
really what I see going on I like I
think I saw a movie recently that I
thought was actually nihilistic that
actually was like a celebration of the
idea that there's a a righteous heroic
there's a there's a heroic value to to
blowing away
your oppressors you know or or to
destroying you know which movie was that
I'm not I want to say I don't want to
say but it disturbed me it scared me but
but but i but I don't think what people
are doing in America or in in England is
is nihilism I think is it it's deep like
desperation and like you said sense of
loss of control loss of you know
marginalization etc and I think that
that's when like that's when you see the
downside of of ego not having a healthy
empowerment right like I think to your
point like like there is a part of ego
that people need a healthy baseline of
it to be able to act in healthy ways
yeah but I think it's so it's never been
easy well first of all to your first
point I think that whole thing is
exacerbated when we have vested
interests who who benefit from fomenting
this sense of chaos that we're seeing
and media gets weaponized to people who
are you know ill suited to you know find
the signal and the noise and act
accordingly and you know I think we're
seeing that in in ways that are
unprecedented in human history and it's
deeply gravely concerning yeah the
amplification intensification of noise
is the speed with which it's happened I
mean cuz I you know we're about the same
age I think I kind of think Gen X is the
is the vanguard generation in terms of
like we're the first cradle we're the
first television informed generation
right and and you could argue that even
though it's it
it's at 1/100 of the speed of what's
happening today we still we had the we
had the inbound Global Information as a
part of our total experience right we've
never not had a sense of the world we
even when I was a kid I could see the
helicopters taking people off the roof
in Vietnam right right like I remember
that in my dad was a vet and so I I
remember his intensity about it but I
remember the image I actually remember
seeing dislocation disruption being
scared of like the Son of Sam murders
even though like I D you know there was
a whole lot of stresses coming you know
that movie the day after yeah oh I just
talked about this with someone the other
day it's like how old you know we were
like terrified by terrified absolutely
terrified like you know and and here in
point being whatever it was that we you
know had to deal with the it's in
comfort it's almost unmeasurable the the
turbocharging of the stresses from
information overload and distortion
through that information now and it's a
it's it's wild it's really wild and
we're also the that were the last
generation to be raised without the
internet so we have the TV you know we
have that that that sort of filtering
ability that came with growing up with
television but also we know what it's
like to you know be educated without the
level of information the influx of of
noise that young people see today and I
can't I can't even wrap my head around
what that must be like and the
downstream impact of that on the next
generation in the generation in that 10
20 years from now yeah it does
it's really weird too because hmm like I
think for all the flak he gets over the
single moment that he played a negative
role in some people's mind in the 2000
election I think that I think that Ralph
Nader for me really articulated almost
as a philosopher better than anybody
earlier than anybody that we have
we have a core conundrum of corporate
interest versus human interest that this
is basil - like everything now it's
basil - our health care problems it's
basil - our environmental problems that
that if we don't if we can't separate
those two things and prioritize human
interest over corporate interest we have
some really really serious problems
metastasizing out of that but what's
weird to me is in what you just observed
the so I used to think to myself like
wow man you can really see the degree to
which we're being turned into corporate
copper tops corporate consumers like
we're being fed entertainment that's
really just sort of a a burger and a
xanax blended together and and all
they're really doing is priming us to
buy [ __ ] right and there's a art leaking
through and this and that but that
matrix of corporate corporate matrix
have ultimately getting you to be a
consumer it was intense but now what's
really wild is yes notionally notionally
it's it's still about selling this stuff
right Facebook Instagram their whole
business model is as an ad platform so
it's indisputable that there is but this
weird thing has happened which is
because they're in the business of
selling ads what it's now turned into is
something that does not have it is not
being driven the manipulation that's
taking place that's really dangerous is
not a manipulation to get us to buy
anything
it's the manipulation literally of how
we feel about each other you know what I
mean and the Russian GRU and this
concerted effort to foment antagonism
within our society to cause chaos and
end social unrest here like this is out
it like out of a James Bond movie or
like Spectre like the only agenda is not
to sell us anything it's literally to
just destabilize us into rage into like
this fit of of such like anger with each
other that that we can't function right
and it's working and then we become
malleable and controllable yeah or at
least unable to organize against mm-hmm
it and you think about like these things
this week this kind of outrageously
horrific showing by you know Mark
Zuckerberg as people say to him do you
care at all about the dissemination of
untruth in this thing you've built and
he cannot summon himself to say no it is
it is like you literally like I just
look at like like in college when you
study like nicho and will to power and
you like content yourself as a 20 year
old that you get what it means but
literally you get to our age and
suddenly you see these moments and you
go no that's actually it right there
that is just pure will to power exactly
as he expressed it it is like it is like
the drive that has no end that says the
ultimate of the ultimate objective is my
maximization period what's so
interesting about that I mean we have
jack dorsey basically coming out and
saying we're no longer gonna do
political ads and he's kind of being
championed but for that right now which
is usually which tees up Zuckerberg to
follow suit which he refuses to do and
when you look at the the the spreadsheet
here the revenue coming from political
ads is so de minimis compared to the
rest of the ad revenue that that that
Facebook reaps in annually so what is
what is this you know this this like
battleground that he's staking his claim
it's will for power it's crazy it's it's
like how much is enough and then you say
well for us or a normal you know kind of
grounded person we wouldn't be in that
position because we don't have that same
will to power or is it that in the
making of that person your career that's
being created as you ascend like does
that happen to somebody or is it that
kind of person that that
sends in that way hard you know yeah
[Music]
that's an interesting chicken in the egg
question I think what what's yeah it's
wild um especially you know I call it
sometimes like it's like the Hosny
Mubarak moment right in the sense that
when you look at like if you just take
Mubarak right mm-hmm
it's a really interesting moment in
contemporary history of the way history
can you know self correct or role and
how you move within it the I'm saying
that value to me Mubarak is this
fascinating contemporary example of the
inability to perceive the opportunity of
the moment because of the habit and
grained in him of seeing himself a
certain way right this is a guy who like
most credible assessments are that he
and his family took something like 30 to
50 billion out of that country over time
and and he had the support of the u.s.
the US intelligence community as a
bulwark against originally you know
communism and then against you know
Islamism Islamic fundamentalism but you
get to this to here square moment right
and he has his George Washington
opportunity he has the moment that
George Washington is now right rightly
legendary for which is he said at the
right moment George Washington said no I
am NOT if it works it has to work
without me right he let the Republic be
more important than him and so he's
forevermore essentially a humanist
political saint right Mubarak had this
moment where if he had looked around him
and looked at his children and looked at
his grandchildren he could have said we
can live we can live like kings for the
next 10 generations in comfort in
Switzerland and lionized
by our own people if I simply go out on
that balcony and say read the tea leaves
and go in this moment you know what
we've done in Egypt in the modern era to
build a strong secular state it involved
things that many people think worse
oppressive that were tough it was a
tough time we did what we thought we had
to do but now the clarion call of people
saying it's time for the next phase is
loud and it's clear and I am NOT gonna
be the person who stands in the way of
it everything I did was to set us up for
this moment and I celebrate the call of
the people to say we need to express
ourselves in this way there would be
statues of him in Egypt for all eternity
no matter who literally just couldn't do
it he'd see it so clearly he could have
put the Muslim Brotherhood on tilt
literally on tilt on their heels unable
to say what can we say about that
nothing it's it's unassailable it's and
and they'd have to essentially say go
off into the sunset enjoy a life instead
he's in the docket you know I didn't you
know it's not dissimilar from the
confounded as to why certain Republican
leaders won't bring break ranks which
was that sort of like if you could just
summon the gumption to stand against
what is happening right now you would be
celebrated and lionized for that yeah
but you know look I wasn't to your point
about it being a rounding error
political ads it's like can you not see
can you not look at this in a wide lens
and project even into the medium-term
future and see what a negative this is
for you to take a stand around something
that is literally atomizing the very
fabric of the democratic capitalist
society that allowed you to build this
company in this way and just like see
how much of an opportunity is here for
you to do what doors he did and
essentially say and by the way like you
know I think Jack's pretty conscious guy
like I actually actually do and I think
it's but but it's also just tactically
wise as wise it's like you don't want to
be on the wrong side of
of the tension between humanist
progressivism and what the historical
record is going to show about this yeah
you know Jack's an interesting case
because I too think he's a very
conscious guy and he did the podcast I
went to his house I spent like the
better part of a whole afternoon with
him and and you know I just got the
impression that this is somebody who is
grappling with very difficult issues
with you know impossible solutions
he's got the world chopping out his feet
to solve them and in order to do the
best that he possibly can he has to
erect these boundaries over his his his
quiet to essentially his serenity so
that he can problem-solve like with his
highest consciousness and I just thought
like that's the kind of person that I
want in that role and then you see the
dialogue around him because he is just
the target for everybody's you know
issues and and angst over you know the
the the disease that is endemic and
Twitter hmm
but who would you rather have in that
position yeah yeah as long you know look
I mean I know because I was involved in
starting a crowdfunding come right for
charity I got to know people in that
space and the pioneers that space where
the guys in Kickstarter right Perry Chen
no I never knew but Yancy Strickler I
got to know a little bit and he ants
he's just put a book out called this
could be our future I think and he talks
about the decision they made really
early on to turn that into a benefit
court of a public benefit corporation
and I think but the book at large it's
really excellent it posits this idea
that basically the idea of financial
maximization being our only value on
personal levels on corporate levels is
isn't is a pernicious underlying
component on all this bad
decision-making and social ill and all
of it and it and that it's a variation
on what mark
Daniel said recently about stakeholder
values versus shareholder values he
Yancey sort of says it's like a Japanese
bento box there needs to be there needs
to be apportionment of the values you're
pursuing yeah not just financial
maximization and I think when you see
you know it is gonna take people saying
is you is what I'm all about the biggest
the biggest version of the thing I've
built or is it that I want the legacy of
the thing I've built to be positive that
big enough it doesn't have to be driven
by like is is it growing devouring is it
like Shiva the the devourer of worlds or
is it or is it like you know something
that's going to actually give back it's
a difficult it's a difficult puzzle you
know especially in a capitalistic system
that that lives and dies on quarterly
profits and you know you know
shareholders say and what's happening it
creates a system that that foments you
know growth as the only metric yeah
until you know we're eating around and
we're at cross-purposes with what you
the vision was to begin with and you
know when I when I when I kind of can't
when I take a ten thousand foot look on
what's happening culturally it's it's
difficult to not cast a dystopian view
or be pessimistic about the future you
know and I talked to lots of interesting
people who provide me with a tremendous
amount of optimism but I find myself you
know lapsing into you know kind of a
dark place with the whole thing yeah the
the thing that kind of buffers me about
that which I agree when I look at I
spend a lot of I've spent years and
years and years working on environmental
issues conservation issues and
sustainable development issues and
things like that and I'm certainly not
like a global expert but I don't know
nothing about you know I've spent enough
time on
and sometimes I I think you know my
dad's a career environmental
conservation litigator and organization
builder and you go there's not one
single signal that's not moving
radically in the wrong direction like
not one you know every issue of like
ecological health on this planet is
moving significantly in the wrong
direction if for stability in terms of
like the biosphere that stuff literally
supported our evolution and our
ascendance not that the planet won't
survive and it's not that we won't
survive in some measure but we're gonna
be like going through cataclysmic shifts
and you kind of go wow man it's just
inevitable like if not our kids are our
grandkids our grandkids it's like what
is the condition of the world they're
gonna live in gonna be it seems really
bleep once in some way but but on the
other hand the other thing that's true
is that within two generations there are
there are evolutions technological and
of ideas all these things that are so
profound that the notion that our
grandparents our grandmas could no more
have imagined information technology in
it has gone beyond any of the science
fiction I mean some of the most most
most prescient thinking in science
fiction has sort of imagined aspects
we're going through but what that means
is we have to have the humility to know
that we also just cannot possibly the
dystopian vision that we imagine well
it's based on our current understanding
of what's policy so we just don't know
we just we just don't know but it's
within the not knowing that I look at it
it's sort of what some people say about
I heard like a priest one time say like
you know Christianity is the bet you
can't lose like if faith is the bet you
can't lose because if you if you act on
the basis of it and it turns out to be
true that there's a heaven and a hell
then you won if you didn't then all you
then you were nicer in life to people
and I kind of think the same about the
environment it's like it's like you we
could be we could be wrong and and there
could be a turn here where we realized
that we know how to plant to two
trillion trees a year and that we're
able to like actually reverse these
effects much faster than we thought we
were et cetera or will be wrong but at
least we won't have like we won't have
to like say to our grandkids like what
did you do during the night I drove of
essentially the argument is even let's
presume that all climate science is
wrong but if we go ahead and and stop
overfishing the oceans and we remove the
plastic out of it and we get you know
get better at everything we we start
farming with regenerative principles we
you know all these things that we can do
these are all to our benefit
irrespective let's say they don't have
impact greenhouse gases emissions at all
like they're still solid practices that
we should be doing yeah and also
actually not of nothing lip it on its
head but there's incredible economies
within this great you know if we care
about growth if we're interested in
enterprise there's unbelievably exciting
future enterprises that will crush
extractive carbon intensive technologies
in the marketplace like I mean that's
that's the thing it's like it's kind of
happening despite all the embedded
subsidies around carbon energy and
everything there's there's some it's
still actually crushing it on a price
point basis renewables are going to
destroy carbon they've already done it
to coal yeah but but renewables are
gonna uh turley destroy carbon-based
energy in the marketplace I just wish we
could get there a little faster yeah you
know well you're interested in in
environmentalism comes from your dad too
by all accounts ounds like you know he's
quite an amazing guy he's he's badass
yeah and you grew up in you grew up in
Columbia Maryland I'm from Bethesda
oh really yeah yeah yeah
grew up you know not too far away and
what's it's interesting because I think
you know people listening probably don't
know but like Columbia was this planned
community and it was developed by your
grandfather right so this interest in
urban planning which spills into the the
movie which we're going to talk about in
a little bit here is kind of this
beautiful way for you to express you
know kind of these ideas that you grew
up with yeah and you sometimes Columbia
gets called the first planned city
uh-huh
which arguably it is because it's now a
city of I think like 120 hundred and
thirty thousand it's not I mean I
remember hearing about it as a kid it
was like this it's planned and it's like
you know this is like this like light
dusting of utopia around it was a
significant testing of utopia I mean we
were it wasn't it wasn't um you know it
wasn't like Margaret Atwood level
cultish but it was but it was um it was
a it was a real yeah they'd had a halo
of of sixties deep progressivism around
it it was a it was for my grandfather an
outgrowth of things he had become
convinced of but also he you know he's
hugely inspired by by Martin Luther King
and in the Canon and John Kennedy and
Robert Kennedy and Columbia was founded
in 67 but it was very much a part of his
conviction that that the spiritual life
of America was going to get corroded by
by the dissolution of the vitality of
cities which to him meant the
dissolution of community yeah and that
and that highways he was a very early he
he articulated and predicted as early as
the mid 50s when he was on Eisenhower's
Housing Commission he he discussed the
idea that that the American highway
system was going to promote low-density
development and that that was going to
create sprawl
and I believe he was a very early like
he was one of the early people to start
using the phrase sprawl and predicting
suburban sprawl in quotes you know and
um and and he and talk about and he
talked about the ways that cities that
city centers were gonna become we're
gonna get denuded you know if Peter left
them for these servers and if these
suburbs were not going to be communities
that they were seeing this by the
fifties already
even with Levittown and things like that
they were seeing that the highway was
promoting a kind of development that had
no center right it was like it was it
was this thing and he he was very
concerned about that he thought that you
know if middle class and upper middle
class life left the cities you'd be left
with essentially what we got which was
like the hyper rich and the hyper poor
it's incredibly pressure I mean that's
exactly what's played out and here we
are in you know living in the greatest
example of that and you know I don't
know what your experience is like living
here but I find it to be very alienating
and it can be extremely lonely like when
I moved here to me years to like
cultivate friendships and some kind of
web of community whereas I always lived
in cities I lived in New York and it's
like you're just in the flow of life and
there's a connectivity there that
doesn't exist here without an extreme
amount of effort no and I've lived in
New York since the week I've moved out
of college I've been there 28 years I'm
a I'm an occasional emigres tell a but I
love um I Love New York you still
consider your main yeah places yeah I've
been a New York resident since the
summer of 91 but but you know my grand
up around my grandfather talking about
these things and it yeah it had to be
and I worked for him my first job out of
college I worked for right his amazing
organization called Enterprise but now
called Enterprise Community Partners
which was pioneering ways of of creating
of developing affordable housing getting
investment equity into affordable
housing development
by really smartly doing it in a non
profit matrix by training
community-based advocacy group to be
nonprofit housing developers and
managers and then getting some equity
from the city but then then leveraging
some through the low-income housing tax
credit which he was he was one of the
you know intellectual fathers of this
amazing program which in our world now
with all the talk about impact investing
right I always say like one of the
earliest and biggest and most successful
impact investment products in the
history of America was the low-income
housing tax credit because it gave an
incentive to invest in affordable
housing development that paid off very
handsomely and so Enterprise alone is
raised and invested something like 16
billion now through the syndication of
the tax credits and through its programs
something like 10,000 community-based
organization partners all over America
you know like a million units of housing
it's it's truly an astonishing of things
amazing that he built I read an analysis
by the Ford Foundation once that like
that one in every 120 families in
America has lived in a unit of housing
created by that organization that's
that's quite a legacy yeah and and and
in indirect you know contra position to
the Alec Baldwin character yeah movie
right who's basically the complete
opposite yeah
he's in a so in in my film which takes
place in the 50s Alec Baldwin plays um a
character who he's not based on Robert
Moses that that would be incorrect
because this is a fiction and there's
lots of things that happen in it from
murders to all kinds of dark
psychosexual secrets that have nothing
to do with Robert Moses they're
completely my invention but but Moses is
indisputably one of the great dark
figures in American life and any is to
me yeah he if my granddaddy's obi-wan
can was obi-wan kenobe the Jedi you know
who held with the force
Robert Moses is like the Jedi who went
dark he's like I started out as a
progressive yeah he did he absolutely
was Anakin Skywalker he he he was
considered by many to in that it to be
like the greatest that the bright light
of the modern urban progressive reform
civil service reform movement and he
went so dark he made a moment I'm not
saying I'm crazy a Star Wars fan I love
but really in an archetypal sentence to
say that Robert Moses was the Darth
Vader of New York in the 20th century is
a completely accurate analogy it's it
because he really was a Jedi Knight who
went dark and was so powerful so
uncontrolled the force for decades for
decades arguably he ran new york city
and state you couldn't do anything
without his say-so from the mid 30s to
at least 1968 so for half of a century
really he he you know for the better for
the better part of the middle of the the
century he controlled New York like an
autocratic Emperor and and yet and yet
he was masked he had the like the Death
Star he had a literally a cloaking she
is genius allowed him to cloak what
everyone thought he was the parks
commissioner and and he in fact
literally was an uncontested Imperial
autocrat who who made every significant
decision about how New York was evolving
from being a 19th century city to being
a twentieth century city and he baked
his racism really into the
infrastructure of New York in ways that
we're still contending with it's uh it's
hard to fathom that level of power from
this shadow figure who was able to
maintain it for so long was such a heavy
hand there is that great there's a I
need to read this book I haven't read it
but Robert Caro wrote a whole book about
this right yeah burns like did a whole
chapter in his his New York The New York
Thank You New York New York documentary
was it's Rick burns I think
directed down the but that that was my
first encounter with it with with him
with this idea that there was a person
who was that powerful who was never
elected and who did so much damage a lot
of good - he was a real visionary but
but an enormous amount of very dark
damage and that and the thing is like
you know it makes my film something like
the documentary which is absolutely not
in the sense that it's first and
foremost a you know an old-fashioned
movie it's a it's a it's a detective
movie it has a it has a a guy with
Tourette's syndrome and
obsessive-compulsive disorder at the
center of it and it's got like jazz
clubs and you know it's his drift it's a
drift in in that period in much the same
way that LA Confidential or something
like that is an atmospheric kind of
experience but I've always thought that
I've always thought that that noir films
when they're serious they do something
really positive which is they if they
don't just acknowledge the shadow in
American life they they dig into it they
basically say there's there's things
going on mmm under the surface of what
we call the American narrative that are
that if we're not paying attention to
them they're doing us real harm like
really serious harm yeah and there's a
there's a disorientation with that with
that trope like with that narrative arc
in that in that you the the movie is
always kind of ahead of the audience in
terms of what the audience no way so
you're never sure like I've heard you
talk about this but like you know
Chinatown is obviously the most
incredible example of this where you
literally don't know what's happening at
all movie until the very end know and
when you don't care because you but also
in for it yeah so they have to work they
have to be really good I mean it's a
heart a weird thing to say because like
a good movie has to be a good movie of
course it does but it but it does have
to it's very particular
because in some ways the point of more
maureen dowd in the new york times wrote
a really great thing about this recently
is that is that it you have to have the
humility to know that the unknowability
of the moment you're living in you do
not know you think you know what's going
on and you don't actually know what's
going on it's why that oj simpson
documentary was pretty amazing because
to me we were young but we lived through
it and we had opinions right and to me
what watching that documentary did to me
talk about ego i could see my own ego i
could hear my own ego from when i was
20-something years old having all kinds
of opinions about those events and the
certainty that he was going to get
convicted and all this stuff and when
you watch the film you're like what and
what a [ __ ] i was to think that i even
understood two out of the six levels of
what was going on here like the social
tectonic plates that were shift exact
led to the inevitability of something
like that happening exactly like like
and the the episode in that that was
dedicated to the history of the
relationship between the LAPD and the
african-american community alone was so
humbling mm-hmm because you're like if
you didn't know this if you didn't know
the depth of this if you knew this you'd
have understood that there was no way he
was getting convicted but if you don't
know this you sat there and with your
opinions thinking that you had any idea
any real basis for understanding what
was going on yeah and and that
unknowability that idea it's very
difficult when you think about it when
you open the paper and you see what's
going on and you think you know what's
going on you have an opinion you just
can't help it like but but pausing and
going you know at what at what point do
you say well we know enough to act but
but we can't really know everything
that's going on it's a very it's a very
profound thing and i think that these
films part of the fun of really good
know our films is that you get
hypnotized they they force you to
experience that uh nobility
understand what's happening right and
and yet they don't alienate you because
they're sexy mm-hmm and I really mean
that word like they're sexy like like LA
Confidential is sexy Chinatown is sexy
The Big Sleep is sexy and what they do
is they that that they flick you go
through some portal and you just go oh
wow this is wild like I'm through I'm
through the screen I'm into the world
it's compelling the music's great
there's things about it they work this
kind of you get into actually like an
aesthetic pleasure of listening to
language and watching people and seeing
clothes but then slowly what they do is
remind you you don't know what's going
on and in this country no matter what
anybody tells you there's dark [ __ ]
going on and not knowing that it's going
on puts you in danger like in big danger
and I think that's pretty healthy
actually yeah and and also clearly has
its parallels as to what's going on
culturally and politically right now but
I think you know I feel a little bit
naked right now because I haven't seen
the movie yeah and this whole thing came
together last night
Amaro night and as like a perfectionist
who who prides himself on his
preparation and who's somebody who's
very detail-oriented
yeah I feel like I'm gonna have like a
Torretta
tick here because I cuz I don't quite
know what I'm talking about but I do
know enough about the noir genre in
general and I and I certainly read up on
this movie it's one of the reasons why
we love this genre is that it's treating
us like adults it's asking a lot of us
but we're welcoming that and it's
refreshing especially in our high
fructose corn syrup you know kind of
entertainment where we're being spooned
without all of this stuff it's so nice
to sit in a theater and be challenged in
that way and I think that there's a real
demand for that like it's almost like
we're starving for it at least in in the
movie theater I mean we're getting a lot
of it in the streaming services right
now like there's tons of amazing
projects that are getting made yeah but
I think it speaks to a larger kind of
cultural thing like I've noticed
that that you know you're someone who
you know feel strongly about your
private life and you're not one to go
out and do all the talk shows and all
that kind of stuff but but you've really
embraced in the in the kind of press
junket with this movie you've embraced
the podcast for me you've done a lot of
the big shows and I think it's well
suited to you because it provides space
to have a nuanced mature conversation
about the things that that you care
about and I think that that is you know
part and parcel it is reflected in the
kind of movies that that you like to
make and certainly in this movie well
thanks I mean here's an interesting
thing though I don't need it's a bad
thing that you haven't seen the film and
maybe we'll come with our friends
tomorrow night and then we talk about it
more but I actually think it's kind of
it's nice in a funny way today because
we're recording this the day the there
today today's opening day and and only
because just knowing what I know about
your own work and story I think it's
interesting to talk about it a little
bit like this but then but not worry
about what the film is about per se or
even the process in making it because
I've been talking about that a fair
amount right what's what's more
interesting today is a walk in and
you've got like David Lynch catching the
big fish which I love and egos the enemy
which I haven't read what I think is
really fascinating is literally what I'm
going through today that is different
from any of these other conversations
and that I think I think connects more
back to things that I'm really
interested in about your own let's call
it like tipping point moment of feeling
like I need to pry our I mean I need to
shift my priorities like if I go real
base on that
I need to get fit or but just really
like I got to shift my priorities is
that the funny thing is is I probably
have not ever I haven't I've threw
myself into this as much as anything
I've done on a creative level by simple
virtue the fact that I wrote I wrote it
produced it directed it raised all the
money for it
it's 20 years in the making yeah it's a
long a long gestation on this one right
and I really and I really couldn't get
it out of my head it was not it was
really not at a certain point about like
the ego of I want to play this role it
really was it started to become for me
about things that I wanted to get across
that I started feeling actually the very
best feeling that you get about a thing
which is like it's and this I have
talked about but it's the Joseph
Campbell transparency effect it's like
this did people will be able to see
themselves in this they will be able to
see us in this they'll be reminded they
believe the now but also like truths
about the past and how we got where we
are and and even just on a personal
level reconnect with empathy which is I
think really really important right now
but mostly I did mostly I just wanted to
I get stubborn about not completing the
thing and I really wanted to complete it
and so I did and so I've thrown myself
out there to talk about it right way
more than I generally know do or want to
because I really do think it's better
for people to figure stuff out on their
own mm-hmm however here's the really
interesting today which is I kind of was
intimating this to you in the kitchen
but the funny thing is is for all the
every form of cultivation we didn't have
there's it's not a ton of financial
support behind putting it out they've
done a good job but it's just not the
kind of film that you if you throw a
hundred million dollars in marketing at
a film like this you're gonna lose 50
million bucks you know that's just the
way it is so I don't expect that so I've
tried to lean into it but what's really
interesting is I know for sure already
today that if not gonna blow the doors
off it's not gonna be some it's not only
not gonna be some record weekend it's
not those same things
it'll be soft like it'll be it'll be
less than then
people hoped it would do in an opening
weekend right so this word times its
temp to me in almost every framework
it's not only not relevant to what I was
trying to do when I did it but I
actually know now from experience on
film specifically that the very best
things I've done and I mean literally
the stuff I've been nominated for Oscars
for the stuff that I haven't but that
people will almost ubiquitously call
cultural touchstones like Fight Club or
American History X or the 25th hour or
none of which got any awards or anything
like that but are generally the first
things named yeah if people say these
things right every single one of those
you've been down this road many times
when I see down this road what I mean is
a considered a financial failure in the
initial assessment of the matrix of like
measuring things by the amount of right
initial box-office they do right but not
by the main metric or the most important
metric which is did we do what we set
out to do yes we say what we wanted to
say yes we the team that created this
thing satisfied that we accomplished
what we you know set out absolutely but
what I'm saying is what's fascinating to
walk in and see this book is I I have
been through it like I've been through
it I've actually experienced the very
rare satisfaction of going through the
feeling of disappointment like when
Fight Club came out we all thought we
made a right but ass-kicker of what she
did right but it came out and everybody
felt stung everybody felt stunned by
that it's so hard to believe that that
was the case yeah I know it was like
booed it was but also it just it just
you know it the budget the film it's
like 68 million bucks and I think it's
total box office in the US was under 40
which means the studio took home 20 so
your earring to like deep in the red
yeah not like partially in the red like
deep in the red right that was the era
when not to get business wonky but the
studio's still
the DVDs and the DVDs on Fight Club
actually made in my understanding ended
up making it sort of a profitable
enterprise but it still it was still
like wow yeah Wow
like we felt the kind of heat we felt
from the people who loved it was like a
once-in-a-career kind of it was like
that feeling of like people get it they
love it they're there feel so connected
to it the level of passion that movie
you know if you're Gen X if you're a Gen
X male I mean that movie was transcended
it's one of their few movies I go back
and watch every single year and it's
it's one of the most impactful movies
I've ever seen in terms of like what I
connect with emotionally and in my
opinion it comes it and it takes you to
a positive place it takes you through
the sexiness of nihilism but back out to
where he grabs the he rejects that he
grabs the girl's hand and he says let's
let's like let's try this a healthier
way right you know there's definitely an
embrace of chaos and anarchy sure sure
on the way I think to saving Elaine from
the church and and running you know it's
the same as the end of the Graduate I
really believe that yeah but but but my
point is we went through that we felt
stunned we came out the back side of it
and you knew that was gonna happen going
no we didn't you know we didn't we felt
we did Brad say to you like people are
good but we but you can't leave is what
I mean about you got you you still go
like God we we thought we made a hit
movie you know we thought made a hit
movie and it's sort of like in some
matrix that's not even the matrix that
we care about that that matrix tagging
it as a disappointment reverberates out
it hits you in the head and you go ahead
like like you questioned yours yeah we
didn't we didn't yeah that sucks like
you feel bad about something that in
your heart you feel good about right and
I think but my point is that even having
been through it when we talk about like
the ego being one of the most pernicious
addictions it's like I've been through
it multiple times like multiple times
you know what I mean and this film that
I've made it's it's as good as anything
I've done like just pull stop I know it
is and I also
you know I've had people Michael Eric
Dyson he's a sociologist to Georgetown
you just wrote a [ __ ] essay on it
that hit me out of the blue I was crying
when I read that was an esquire piece
yeah it's an incredible article it's and
it's partially about the film but it's
also partially about what it inspired in
him to think about on race in America
and Ken Burns wrote this essay yeah
about it that I had me I was I was on
the floor he's a hero of mine and I'm
like there's this whole side of me right
now that's like I did what I said and
have phrased the movie more highly no
you didn't know medium article and I
Anna and what and there's a big part of
me that's like if literally like
Chinatown it's like that
the psychic part the Jake gets in my
house is that in my head is saying he's
saying how much is enough like how much
more do you need like what more could
you want and the answer the best part of
me is for sure
nothing like that's it that's what
you're going for you're going for
activation pleasure and activation and
is that happening it's happening I can
feel it I can see it and this will find
its level and people will get to it and
all these things but on a day when the
distribution head at Warner Brothers
calling you up and saying it's gonna be
a little softer than we want despite our
best efforts and your brain just slams
you and I don't mean like goes yeah okay
but you know hang you know gotta hang in
there you're saying all these things
like it literally becomes like a
Tourette ik conversation right you can
you're saying these things and you
there's a voice that goes but yeah well
we're playing with this plays out on a
longer horizon this is like but still
there's Daniel Kahneman little Breslow
there's a residue from that right but
this is what's interesting to me this is
what's totally fascinating to me is it's
not a residue
it's a big [ __ ] loud frustrated side
of your head that is the ego and goes
[ __ ] I I wanted I wanted F I wanted
everyone else's version of of what we
want to be fulfilled to you know worse I
mean there's something refreshingly
human about that because the narrative
that that circles around you
somebody who's who's you know who's kept
the press at arm's length who's had
their brush ups with you know kind of
sketchy narratives swirling around yes
it mayor Pete not have happened and
who's really carved out a private life
and with that comes the inference or the
assumption like well this guy just
doesn't give a [ __ ] about what anybody
says about him yeah he's just doing his
thing and like that's cool and that's
like a superpower that I wish that I
could have and so when I'm scrolling or
whatever looking at looking for feedback
like I feel weak you know what I mean I
feel like yeah my ego has the better of
me and I think that speaks to the whole
kind of Torretta thing right because
Tourette's what is Tourette's but a very
severe example of what we all kind of
Harbor which is this war inside of
ourselves between our better instincts
and the behavior that we actually
manifest in the world yeah and what what
what I'm kind of fascinated about is
it'll you know I I'm a big believer in
that sort of this too shall pass thing
you can let that's like Dharma right
that's you you can let you can watch
your your base your base instead your
base impulses and desires just go like
hit like it's like someone hit a guitar
string really hard and it's just going
you know but it's gonna it's gonna
settle down it's gonna settle down and
then the work you're doing your life
like all these things go and actually
the long-term steadiness of the thing
you've made itself and its quality and
all these things
it'll be out there yeah will find its
life yeah well everything will find its
level and in many cases you will be you
can have faith that like yeah it's gonna
get to that place that is ultimately the
best thing also which is just the
quality of the thing will hold itself up
and it will be all good but kind of
fascinated at one point today I was kind
of flow
along looking at the light like in the
Hills and I was sort of thinking well
this was an interesting experiment in I
cared a lot right I put like more of
myself into this that you know on
multiple levels that wasn't just an
actor working for a great director or
whatever I did it so then I went out and
said well I have to do for measure of
trying to engage in the a wide net of
the very people who I know like
substance who like long-form
conversations who like rich meals and by
the way a lot of the cheap ones too and
the thing is you come as thing you go
well I didn't really do anything you go
you go
Wow so like so moving the needle at all
yeah it doesn't move the needle at all
and this we were kind of talking about
this too in the kitchen is in the world
were in it's like you know Henry Louis
Gates Jr like who was like one of the
rising rock stars of history and
academia when I was in college and he's
like one of our art elders you know one
of our great he wrote a beautiful thing
about it today right and I saw like you
know people who did born person do you
see this thing and retweet this and do
this these things and you just go it's
not doing anything it's not doing
anything man it feels good it's like but
it's like it talked about pissing in the
wind I think they I think I think some
of this stuff is doing something you
know you did Rogen yesterday oh yeah
millions of people watch that like it's
it's I mean you're doing everything that
you can and that's a demonstration of
how much you care and I think that and
and I'm finding you to be like I had
this thing like is he gonna be all like
walled off and like not wanting to talk
it's like that's not the experience that
I'm having at all yeah that's not the
experience I'm getting when I'm I tuned
into those other shows as well mostly
I've said this many many times it was
not an insincere statement I'm not like
I don't think most people who know me
think that aloofness is my is my natural
state right I am pretty engaged but I
but
my reticence around like public
discourse is actually I just really
honestly think it it screws with the
quality and experience that people have
when they go in to see the kind of work
I do it's like I don't think like I know
Daniel day-lewis a little bit I know
Sean Penn a little bit but Daniels
better example because he's like the
warrior monk in our tribe of thespians
he's the true like warrior monk and I'm
by that I mean he's like in you have no
I didn't no one knows where he is he's
not in the cave this whole like we do
anything for such a long time you know
and he's a really terrific person he's
fascinating person he's all these things
but he descends off the mountain and
delivers these lightning bolts to me I
am in I am just flattened by his
performances they are so visceral and so
vital and deep just deep as [ __ ] and but
that is enhanced by the fact that I
don't see him and hear him yeah and he
goes away for a long long time and when
he brings it back down it's got like the
level of excitement
it's just crud also anything I held from
before is atomized it's gone it's long
gone
and there's just the shock of the
reincarnation
it literally liked it dead and gone and
then it's reincarnation into yet another
like like powerful thing right and
that's coming it's it's becoming
increasingly more and more rare the
level of discipline that you have to
have with the with the kind of exposure
that's available to everybody now
requires you know a sense of self that
is increasingly important more difficult
I think like you know I know you've
talked about like you know Dylan and
Bowie and and and even like Radiohead
you know is probably a decent example of
that like they you know like they're not
when when you're purposely removing
yourself from the public eye and you go
out and you do your thing and you come
back like that's a that's a [ __ ]
cool thing yeah yeah um what's
interesting that what I'm interested in
really specifically is to me this whole
though the process of trying to to and
some of it I'm being totally candid I
didn't feel I had any choice in this
case I'd love to let it fly and let it
be
I'd be more okay in a way it would sting
less to me if I hadn't made such an
effort you know I mean like this
distinct part of the brain that's like
god damn I did all this stuff and is it
really even doing anything
the the drive for me was not even the
care of the thing itself because the
thing itself is like a child you think
you're once you've put it out it's on
its own path but it's more that I didn't
I engaged people wonderful people who
backed me in taking some risk and
putting some chuckles they put their
money alongside Warner in this and I
like really appreciate it right like I
don't have any right to that from
anybody there's no nothing about my work
that to me automatically validates that
someone should should put you know like
a lot of money into backing me doing
this thing so my view is sort of like I
owe these allies of mine literally
everything I've got everything I've got
to try to make them make it so they at
least get a hole on it ironically these
are the type of people who are like you
did because the thing is like beyond
what we could have hope honestly the
response I've gotten it doesn't and I
feel good about that but at the same
time I want to try to do right by them
on in the business of it all and and I
don't the thing the funny thing is is it
it it burns you down
it just does there's no two ways about
it and this is where it's part but all
this talking about it or yeah no not
just talking about just the track that
it's a lot of travel a lot of them it's
just a lot it's it's not emotional
stress but it's just
wait when you stew anything and this is
I am I am really interested in asking
you a question which is you get to this
point where you're sort of like wow I'm
not doing I'm not doing any of the
things that I know are healthy for me
like I I am NOT an uninformed person
about like diet I am NOT I serve I have
lots and lots
I used to I rowed competitively in
college I've been an athlete I've been
I've trained I've gotten in really good
shape I've starved myself I've gotten
back down to like 137 to do the Painted
Veil ran the New York Marathon and your
side yeah yeah I've done I've done a lot
of stuff I I actually have in me a
certain measure of what I'd call the
muscle memory of health and discipline
right and when you get into this mode
we're grinding up in here like tapping
my forehead you know it's amazing I am
so amazed at how fast the inertia effect
the mind just takes you to you get into
it's not even oppositional you just
don't the speed with which discipline
around what you eat and how much you
move your body falls away in the face of
let's call it stress I don't mean
emotional stress but just yeah the
clinical stress of doing some pursuing
something at a high in a high gear right
and number one you talk about the
argument with the head the amount of
self chastising I do on a daily basis
would be so much more easily resolved by
just waking up and doing yoga for 40
minutes or grabbing my board and going
out and paddling for 30 minutes and
going into the exact day that I'm going
to have anyway it would be so much more
easily resolved by fasting or doing the
green juice cleanse while I'm doing this
instead of drinking three [ __ ]
coffees a day to get myself through it
and I'm super curious in Europe because
I've been hit
Tai's doughty eating sugar had that work
for like a year year and a half falling
off of it you know gotten but to me the
beta of the swings the volatility on it
is getting I'm 50 now yeah my level of
frustration with the volatility is
maxing out yeah like I really really
coming out the back side of this
especially feeling like I'm feeling
today which is like deep satisfaction
short-term frustration I'm like I do not
want a tip right now particularly I do
not want to tip over into sort of a sigh
and more indulgence of negative pattern
ill-health yeah I really really right
now want to go out the back of this into
like a new level of resolve and I'm
super curious like I'm sure you've
talked about it but I'm super curious
for you what the tricks are of like
sustained discipline through phases like
when you're a race is like a movie for
me it's super easy to if you've got
goal-oriented things that's the best you
can always like set yourself like I got
to get ready for this film or I gotta
get ready for this goal but I'm at the
point in my life where I don't want to
do that many films I don't I don't want
to do a film a year that I have to get
in shape for right I want to like I want
to have a steady state discipline I'm
super curious do you go through still oh
yeah without a doubt
I mean the first thing I would say to
you is is is stop chastising yourself
and be a little bit more gentle on
yourself because you're in this short
term window where you're exerting a
tremendous amount of will on the world
for something that you care deeply about
your values like if I look at it like
you have you have different values that
are competing with each other right now
for your attention and resources and
your priority at the moment is getting
the word about out about this movie that
you worked so hard on that you care so
deeply about and trying to foment
interest and getting other people to
care about it in the way that you
there is a there's an expiration date on
this phase that you're going through and
I think just to begin with just
recognizing that you're in a heightened
period at the moment and and being okay
with the fact that you're not gonna be
in this super balanced state while you
while you go through this in the same
way that you would think about pushing
other things aside or or marginalizing
other values because you're training for
a marathon or you're in production on a
movie like those are where you have to
choose which value is going to take
precedence in this equation but I think
in and I would say to you that this
there's this illusion that we're all
striving for this perfect balance in our
life and I think it's setting people up
myself included to feel like we're
falling short or disappointing ourselves
and others because we can't meet that
like you know what's your morning
routine and what time are you waking up
and like are you doing these 20 things
in the morning so that you can be your
best self when you navigate the world
and all the other you know obligations
that you have to meet throughout the day
and I've just found for myself that I
can't necessarily meet that on a day to
day basis and it's been a journey to
just being okay with that and and
looking at a couple of the things that I
can do or what is completely unknowable
non-negotiable that you're gonna do no
matter what is happening like what is it
that you feel stroke so strongly about
that actually is really crucial to your
self-care that that you're gonna create
that protective boundary around like
maybe it's getting out on the water and
surfing for you know it doesn't have to
be thirty minutes what it's 15 minutes
or something that's actually doable and
for you was was getting was going vegan
one of those threshold things where you
said this has got to be essentially part
of the fundamental yeah I mean I I come
I you know I came into that first you
know I have a long story of like
addiction and recovery and went to rehab
and all that kind of stuff so I I kind
of I've learned how to see certain
things through the lens of like 12-step
and there's a rubric with that that
creates kind of a binary system that
removes decision fatigue like you're
either drinking or doing drugs
you're sober but you can't like drink it
you know it's like right there's a
there's a there is a Iron Curtain
between those two things and when 10
years later I had this you know brush
with ill health and realized that I was
once again facing another you know kind
of threshold moment for myself I
approached diet and lifestyle with the
same kind of rigor and you know binary
perspective that 12-step offered which
you know I played around with a lot of
diets and wasn't getting anywhere but
there's something about plant-based that
not only when I tried it like I just
felt amazing yet in order to sustain it
I kind of leveraged the tools of 12-step
to create a foundation as I started to
learn how to do it it's like well you
know meat and dairy are just off the
table just like drugs and alcohol like
not made it very easy for me and that
was imperfect at first but allowed me to
kind of move forward with it as I
learned how to like perfect it and make
it sustainable and and that's something
I've helped you know I've held that line
for 12 years but my relationship with
like Fitness training and exercise like
I stay connected to it but you know
there's a big difference between how I'm
living now versus when I was training
for these races and it's like a job you
know it's like being in production
you're 25 hours a week on yeah out of my
bike or whatever it's not a sustainable
lifestyle it's something that I can do
for a period of time to achieve a
certain goal and then you have to
rebound back so that pendulum you know
in my life my pendulum is always
swinging and that that idea that like
fantasy of balance is that you know that
pendulum is always kind of right in the
middle there and it's not my life that's
not about the life of almost any high
performer that I know it's more about
getting comfortable with those swings
and understanding that and in the short
term your life is out of balance but
when you telescope out like over an
extended period of time you're making
sure that the important things in your
life are being attended to right do you
on a pure in the matrix of just actual
training and the value of on on top of
like plant-based eating within because
training and exercise and all of it are
so good not only for your your heart
health and you know
everything else but but for your
well-being then the meditative quality
mind clearing quality of exercise in the
state you know the mood stay with the
serotonin that comes from it all the
yeah all the good you know kind of
keeping you even components of a do have
you found that let's say train for a
race for you or an event is like like
doing a film and you might say I don't
actually want to do as much of this as
I've done it in the past so the spreads
between those goal driven you know
phases get why yeah right yeah yeah have
you experienced though that within
within the wider spreads between highly
motivated you know job like things have
you seen have you ever gotten to a place
where the baseline of what you're doing
to sustain not for not for job really
reasons we're for it but almost just
like for your mental well-being your
health has dipped like you know to not
to zero but almost to like where you're
like god I'm almost back to it yeah to
100% yes you know and I'll beat myself
up a lot know yeah there's this idea
like I go out know how much is you run
today fifty miles I'm like dude you
would laugh if you knew like some you
know like only worked out like twice
this week I think like it's you know
it's at a pretty low boil at the moment
and you know if I had my druthers I
would be you know hitting it every
single day and that's that's not the
reality of my situation because I'm
making a conscious choice to invest my
time elsewhere you know what I mean like
like I wanted to spend several hours of
immersing myself in your world today
afraid you came over here so we could at
least have some seven in telogen
conversation and and and so you know
ordinarily I would have done something
different this morning but I'm like
totally a hundred percent okay with that
yeah and I think that's that comes a
little bit I think maturity has helped
that whereas maybe several years ago I
would be holding myself to a standard
that I could
sustained like I would just wake up at a
ridiculous hour to get it in and I and I
would burn myself out and and now it's
like it's okay man you know yeah I'm not
going to get to do everything you want
to do every single day right what can I
do and one of the small little habits
that I can cultivate to make sure that
I'm not really losing you know touch
with or contact with those important
aspects of lifestyle yeah it's the the
the even as I'm listening to it and you
know spinning on the patterns of thing
it just is it's always wild the the
dance between the destructor the the way
that structured approach to time in life
can bring actual richness you know what
I mean it's not even just discipline and
effectiveness like getting effectiveness
is like in a way [ __ ] it's like it
actually is like if you just focus on
quality of life like some structure can
mean that you actually are learning
music and you actually are staying a
little healthier and you're you're
learning new things because you're
you're making time like through teachers
you know what I mean like through by
booking it literally or you know and and
the structure can see on seem like anal
and not like relaxed yeah but the truth
is is that struck more structure in the
time can make can help you kind of
wrangle yourself into doing the things
that you're actually really happy that
you're learning and you're feeling good
yeah at the end of the day and your life
feels good but that's at odds with it's
just at odds with like pure presence
right or like the value of like kind of
just being allowing yourself to be you
know what I mean
and it's like yeah it's true it's like
you can overthink balance and stuff but
the but the the I find myself really
admiring people who
who somehow achieve kind of like they
they're minimizing the Vall you know
what I mean cuz I cuz I think I think
having sort of crossed a certain
threshold where I've lost you know my
mother died when she was 54 and my
really good friend and partner who I
built a theatre company with he died at
56 and you know and you just kind of go
like like you know the consequence of
negative behavior starts to speed up a
little bit or you start to go you know
you don't want be eating you wanna be
like 50 years old meaning now a buddy
can't you can't get away with it anyway
you're don't you don't mean dare you
don't mean sugar you don't to be eating
like like casein protein and and sugar
that's just like rocket fuel for cancer
you know what I mean and it's like and
every and that's like a clinical fact
and and but so like people I feel like
people who somehow Titan bring the you
know you can't be in the hyper gear all
the time but you don't want to go like
like down into letting hyper gear on
something else rationalize like your
health falling through the floor yeah
you know yeah yeah that's it that's a
big kind of part of the sober journey
too because you come in as this you know
alcoholic drug addict and those are
people who are they've just they have
really high highs and really low lows
and there's there's that's part of the
addiction like that's part of the
craving can I get that hot it that high
and like what happens when I go that low
and there's like a there's like an
affinity for the drama that comes with
that as well and what you have to learn
over time is is is what it feels like to
be in that middle place or when that
valence it you know is shrunk so that
you're in a more compact range and
that's uncomfortable too because you're
like if you if you you know if you if
you want that high high then you have to
have that low low you can't have one
without the other
yay and what does it feel like to
navigate life where
you're just keeping it a little bit more
in check and that's hard yeah it's funny
I I have multiple friend I have friends
who are in recovery who I think it's
really funny like I think in some ways I
there are friends of mine who are in
recovery who I think are in many ways
heading into middle life in a better
place then then some of us who haven't
gone through recovery because it's
almost like the experience of bonding
them out younger got them to like
understand that middle band better and
there's ways in which I I don't envy it
because a lot of people die too
yeah you know what I mean that's like
you can't like and I know a lot of
people who died like who didn't get
through that which is brutal like it's
like you just like you were you were you
were friends with Phil rightful Hoffmann
yeah I was I was I was friends with Phil
but I was I was more like colleagues of
I mean we were like he I was not like he
wasn't one of like my my best and
closest pals but we came up in the same
period together and and we had a we had
a a year where we did like two films
back-to-back the second one was the one
we did with Spike Lee who was a big
figure for both of us just in terms of
inspiration someone we both really
looked up to and I think like I bond I
kind of bonded with him more on that he
was always to me someone and especially
he was someone who was like you wanted
like everybody admired him so much all
of us who came up in New York in that
era like Mark Ruffalo and Bobby
Cannavale II and even many of us you
know Phil was he was the guy yeah it was
like he really was he was like one of
those people you admired so much that he
was like it's so ironic but he was like
the guy in it's like in high school
it's like the jock or whatever but and
phil was the furthest thing from that
but he was like the guy you wanted his
approval yeah you know you wanted his
like he what you wanted to be in the
club of what Phil and would he give it
out grudgingly grudgingly and I and I
think but no but I think it made it all
the more special yeah a little I think I
realized that you realized that
sometimes like what you're feeling off a
person doesn't anything to do with you
it has to do with what what they're
going through or maybe but he didn't
suffer fools like he really and some of
my really good friends were super super
good friends with him and and he
definitely didn't suffer fools which is
part of why you wanted the a permit
affirmation from him special but we did
we did these two films and when we did
this by clay film together I we we it
was kind of the dream we rehearsed it
like a play and I felt I felt it was one
of those things that was meaningful to
both of us and we bonded a little bit
over the specialness of that and then we
were both doing plays kind of next door
to each other for the rest of that year
so it was it was that was kind of like
the no but but it's you know it's
unfathomable to me then that it not even
about being friends he's just
unfathomable to me that that like we
lost him he's not here yeah it's it's um
it kills me and uh and that's said from
the point of view of him not having been
one of my best friends I just I can't
believe that you know you that like the
the scale of the loss is really bad and
I and I know many others also who write
like you know we all do I mean so it's
not like you can't like Rome obviously
romancing romancing an addiction is if
that's its own cult you know what I mean
I mean that's its own like like there's
there's too much of that and I think the
truth of it is it's really there's a lot
of there's there's a lot of people
totally lost to it that but I do think
that I know a lot of people in a weird
way I admire the
I might where they got to through it you
know and in some ways I I
they probably they would say don't
because I'm static yeah and the danger
that's there is lurks or whatever yeah
but sometimes I look at him like wow
that there's a discipline there that I
feel like I'm it's it's like it's not
heroin but I but I feel like you're mine
when you feel like you're not mastering
your your balances there's a saying in
12-step like grateful alcoholic or
grateful addict and for a long time I
couldn't understand what that meant but
but you know I've learned to really get
that and what it basically what it means
is like listen you have this affliction
and the problem is so manifest that
you're forced to confront it and as a
result of that you're given these tools
and a community of people who want to
support you and you learn how to
basically be vulnerable to develop this
capacity for compassion and self inquiry
and all of these things that ultimately
if you clean into them and actually you
don't make use of them and avail
yourself of their power have this
incredible potential to improve your
lives improve lives and and help other
people improve lives and and I think you
know when you see when you see those
people out in the world like you know
there's a lot of people who are just
living their lives reactively who don't
spend a lot of time on self inquiry or
self-improvement and and so you know
yeah I would consider myself one of
those grateful people for for you know
short of that I don't know that I would
you know first of all be alive but
secondly be interested in these things
that have helped me and so many other
people yeah yeah it's um and it and it's
also like a it's a it it's like is the
ebb and the flow of like the desire to
like contribute or let's just call it
put out versus like to take the time
- just be quiet and inboard you know I I
kind of feel I don't if you feel this
way but I feel like one of the downsides
it's less discussed of of all this high
speed thing is that a lot in a lot of
ways what it's really pernicious about
this about these platforms about this
social media all of it is it in loud
ways what it does is it it goes like
this constantly on the ego and it but
what it really says is it says there's a
way for you to make your life matter all
you have to do is tell people about it
all the time you know what I mean like
and and and by telling when you tell
people about it and they give you this
little hit of affirmation you go woo
that was that you know like my life
matters right but but until that one day
that you say the thing that isn't quite
right and there one decides to cancel
you yeah but the but the but what's
fascinating to me or horrifying is sort
of that that it it creates like it turns
everybody into a fast-food purveyor
right that it's like yes there's people
rioting pretty profound things on some
of these things but ultimately I think
it's part of an addiction to to the idea
that if I'm not putting out if I'm not
putting out like if I'm not doing exist
in yeah if I'm not telling my story I'm
not here and and and it's like I can't
help wondering is it like eradicating
the room people are making in their
lives to just like be quiet like just be
quiet I think it is without a doubt and
I've noticed it in my own and not and
not actually just scroll the the
bite-size things but like actually read
like one of these many things you know
the amount of freaking books that are in
my house that I I really want to read
yeah that I'd be so much happier to have
read than anything you know I'm Megan
scroll but it's so much easier to scroll
and you have to I mean murder that's a
discipline like you really have to erect
these boundaries and exert a level of
discipline just to just
to be bored just to be able to like give
yourself a little bit of a refractory
period you know yeah tween thoughts and
I don't know where that's going cuz it's
it's getting harder and harder yeah it
is and that and I think that's going to
denigrate the the quality of creative
output ultimately how could it not yeah
I find myself it's sort of like Jack
White's song you know you're sitting in
your little room you've tried to do
something good but if you do something
good you're gonna need a bigger room you
know what I mean like and then you'll
have a bigger room and you might not
know what to do and you'll sit around I
came from the line just sit around
wondering how you got started packing up
your little roomies and it yeah and it's
like that could be why younger people
produce like vital stuff I don't know
you know I mean I well there's always a
reaction yeah you know but but I think
there's actually a fossil Havel the
Czech president it's like a hidden
little thing in his essays but he has
this essay called second wind that's
basically kind of about how difficult it
is to to stop and and in you know take
things on again and risk risk
not another phase of doing of creating
or whatever that does not replicate what
you've been doing yeah
and that it's that it's like the biggest
dare but that the that everything else
is essentially like you're just turning
the you're turning the same yeah you're
guarding me exactly you're perpetuating
what you already know works and I've
heard you talk about this I mean this is
you know classic the classic Dylan
example Bowie again yeah these people
who have the courage and the tenacity to
basically when the stakes are super high
just pivot completely and something your
dad did in his career right he did yeah
yeah he's he was a he's got a great
tapestry you know like I think or I
don't even know what the right analogy
is but I definitely like the idea of
looking the idea of being older and
looking back and going
you know I I for all intents and
purposes like you know charge myself off
doing the same thing mmm because it
because people told me I was good at it
that's that's pretty depressing actually
like if you imagine being old and
looking back and going do I want like
affirmation over and over and over and
over and over again for one or two
things that I figured out or what I like
to look back and go yeah I I have a rich
I have a rich you know landscape of
experiences that are more you know which
which one would you envy more if you
were sitting at 50 and you said I can
live to 100 and this is what I'd like to
look back on nobody would choose that I
mean yeah but when I maybe some people
would when I look at your career though
I mean even if you didn't act at all and
make movies like you you have like like
more on your plate than most people that
I meet I mean you're involved in all
these philanthropic efforts these
environmental concerns you've got tech
companies that you're working with I
mean you you have your hands in like a
lot of [ __ ] yeah what's interesting
though is that it to the point though is
yes but that's not the same as that's
that's like the opposite of quiet uh-huh
you know what I mean like and it's
certain point one things I think is
really wild is the recognizing that once
you set certain things in motion
unwinding them takes way longer than
you're telling us you're going to when
you start and the obligation to other
people and sense of responsibility the
long tail on that is really long
it's like it it's it's it's a lot harder
to it's a lot harder to to give yourself
any kind of real contemplative pause
when you've stacked a lot of things
because well I whined one thing - yeah
cuz you can whine I can finish this
movie can put it out I can say I'm done
with it I don't want to talk about it
anymore go enjoy it and you know god
bless but that it doesn't you know it
that wouldn't mean I'm like
automatically like surfing in you know
fasting it right
yeah there's a lot and so it's like you
you it takes a little bit unwind thing
so how do you make I mean you're getting
I'm projecting but I imagine you're on
the receiving end of like a shitload of
opportunities and things that you could
say yes to what is your rubric for what
you decide to get get involved with like
how do you make those kind of decisions
mm-hmm right now it's so much like
nothing new I mean right now really like
like my determination is is so strong
not to take on anything it's just to see
through the things that been like that
this was a determination to see it
through though yeah like I mean I really
believed in it but I also just was like
I I need I want to see this through
there's other things I'm engaged with
I'd rather see them through then add
anything new you know because also I
think when I mean when kids come into
the mix it's just sort of like right the
last thing you want to be doing is
stacking some new thing that's pulling
you even more away and so I'm like not
gonna spin any new plates so when people
say what's next you just bristle no I
know you think about like what that is
like what is that pivot or that one or
that reinvention yeah I that's why I'm I
think we should wrap on is um you'll
come see the film and I'm gonna read
your book okay no because I am like
waving all your free time no no no I
because I am completely that pivot the
pivot that's exactly the pivot that I am
like most interested in right now I am
really interested in a recovery of
optimal health I can help you with that
yeah cool um thanks for talking to me
man totally that was super fun yeah
miss Blair has a few good ideas now and
then does he oh yeah I know right you've
got a lot of energy that guy I know
sipping from a firehose
bless them yeah motherless Brooklyn
theaters everywhere definitely go check
it out as it will I and Edwards pretty
easy to find if you want to hit them up
got an internet at Edward Norton on
Twitter it's not the best place yeah
wherever you want right until I turn to
see the movie yeah cool man how do you
feel good thanks a lot good all right
thanks man
[Music]